This September, get ready for a whole new
round of great Netflix programming.
Headlining the month is Maniac, which stars
Jonah Hill and Emma Stone as two participants
in a medical study that goes disastrously
wrong.
Other highlights include new seasons of Netflix
originals Iron Fist and American Vandal, along
with the original film Hold the Dark.
In fact, there's so much heading to Netflix
in September that it's hard to keep track
of everything, so we've rounded up the best
new releases to look forward to next month.
"Let's get down to the nitty gritty."
Here's everything good coming to Netflix in
September 2018.
Atypical: Season 2
Critics and audiences loved the first season
of Atypical, which follows a high schooler
on the autism spectrum as he does his best
to navigate school and family life.
With comedy and drama in equal measure, Atypical
was quick to draw in a loyal fan base, and
Kier Gilchrist in particular delivered a winning
performance as the main character, Sam.
Season 2 will pick up right where the first
season left off, following Sam's dysfunctional
family as they deal with their particular
brand of atypical drama.
Look for it on September 7th.
Marvel's Iron Fist: Season 2
Even though Iron Fist has the unfortunate
legacy of being the least-liked Marvel show
on Netflix so far, that hasn't stopped the
character from making an impact.
Iron Fist showed up in the team-up series
The Defenders, and now he's back with a second
season of his standalone show.
"You back for more?"
"Oh, we've not even started."
Will the new season manage to rise above the
rocky foundations laid out in its first outing?
Find out when Iron Fist returns on September
7th.
American Vandal: Season 2
We didn't think it was possible, but American
Vandal is getting even more meta in Season
2.
In the first season, the show revolved around
a vandal who defaced a school.
In Season 2, someone named the Turd Burglar
is spiking the cafeteria food.
But the line is blurring between fact and
fiction.
From scenes of their own show on Netflix to
emails between Netflix and the made-up documentarians
who "investigated" the original crimes, American
Vandal Season 2 is plunging so deep into parody
that it's even mocking itself.
Get caught up in the mystery on September
14th.
BoJack Horseman: Season 5
For four seasons of horseplay and nihilism,
BoJack Horseman has alternately stunned, broken,
and uplifted audiences.
The story of a has-been sitcom star who's
still trying to chase the dream in Hollywood,
it's the kind of show that plays like a comedy,
only to sneak up on you with pain and sadness.
"One drink."
What can we expect when Season 5 lands?
Honestly, with BoJack Horseman there's no
telling, so we'll all have until September
14th to find out.
Maniac: Limited Series
Netflix has been dropping teasers for Maniac
for months now, and we're still not entirely
sure what the series is about.
The premise is no secret: Jonah Hill and Emma
Stone are two strangers who take part in a
pharmaceutical trial.
After that, all bets are off as the trailers
dive into a montage of paranoia and alternate
realities.
We do know that Cary Fukunaga, the mastermind
behind True Detective and the screenwriter
of It, is helming the series, which promises
a dark journey into the human psyche.
Check it out on September 21st.
Quincy
Rashida Jones rose to fame as Ann Perkins
on Parks and Recreation in 2009, and she's
been going nonstop ever since.
"Ann Perkins!"
"Aaaaaaaan Perkins!"
The actress is the daughter of legendary musician
and producer Quincy Jones, and now Rashida
is turning her sights on dear old dad with
Quincy.
The documentary will offer an intimate look
at Quincy Jones' professional career and his
private life.
Take a look on September 21st.
The Good Cop
Netflix's upcoming series The Good Cop marks
the streaming service's first foray into procedural
crime shows anchored by quirky, off-kilter
detectives.
The series stars Tony Danza and Josh Groban
as a father and son, both of whom are NYPD
cops.
Well, the father used to be, at least - until
he was kicked off the force and sent to jail
for seven years.
Now, his son is a straight-laced, by-the-book
detective who's trying hard to stay away from
the corruption that landed his dad behind
bars.
"I taught him everything I know."
"Except right from wrong."
Look for it on September 21st.
Norsemen: Season 2
On the surface, Norsemen looks like a spoof
of shows like Vikings and Game of Thrones,
but watch a little longer and you'll find
so much more than that.
Norsemen anchors its many jokes with its own
characters, storylines, and surprisingly rich
production design.
"Farewell brother."
"Why don't you just let me do it, because
I…"
"No, no, it's just my hands are very cold."
It's not a comedy style for everyone, but
with Season 2 heading for Netflix on September
26th, you'll have plenty of time to give Norsemen
a chance.
"You have something that belongs to me."
"We're actually in control here, so…"
Hold the Dark
From Jeremy Saulnier, the director of Blue
Ruin and Green Room, Hold the Dark is about
a writer who's summoned to Alaska to track
down the wolves that carried off a woman's
son.
Once he starts digging into the case, though,
he finds that there's more to the story than
he'd realized.
Westworld's Jeffrey Wright stars alongside
Alexander Skarsgard and Riley Keough.
Look for Hold the Dark to hit Netflix on September
28th.
New original standup
Netflix always has a few treats for stand-up
comedy fans, and September is no different.
On the 11th, look for Daniel Sloss: Live Shows.
The Scottish comedian will be hitting on a
range of controversial topics with his trademark
humor style.
On the 18th, look for D.L.
Hughley in an all-new Netflix special entitled
Contrarian.
With everything from Black Panther to current
politics on the table, it's bound to be an
entertaining show.
New movies
This September, you'll get the chance to explore
the high seas, battle for evil ex supremacy,
and take a walk on the wild side - and you
can do it all without ever leaving the couch.
On September 1st, check out action favorites
like Spider-Man 3, King Kong, and Pearl Harbor.
Then, look for Black Panther on the 4th, Scott
Pilgrim vs. the World on the 16th, and Pirates
of the Caribbean: The Curse of the Black Pearl
on the 25th.
If watching Topher Grace lose his mind to
an alien symbiote in Spider-Man 3 doesn't
do it for you, you can also watch him lose
his mind in a haunted house with the 2018
thriller Delirium.
"Ooh my spider sense is tingling, if you know
what I'm talking about."
Delirium arrives on the first, side-by-side
with screamers like Stephanie, The Keeping
Hours, and The Texas Chainsaw Massacre: The
Beginning.
And on the 17th, make sure you tune in for
The Witch, 2016's most terrifying movie about
Puritans.
There won't be a lot of new drama films heading
to Netflix in September, but the few that
are are definite winners.
In particular, be sure to look for Scarface,
Unforgiven, and The Cider House Rules, the
Oscar-winning drama about a World War II orphanage.
"I hate orphans."
"Say it again to my face!"
"I hate them!"
If you're looking for something lighter, the
first of the month sees a handful of comedies
joining the Netflix ranks.
You'll get classics like Groundhog Day right
alongside modern favorites like Bruce Almighty,
The Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy, and
Nacho Libre.
New television
Netflix's television selection is ratcheting
up the horror this month.
The biggest new addition is American Horror
Story: Cult, which is hitting Netflix on September
18.
Earlier in the month, you can also dig into
Season 3 of Quantico on the 2nd, Season 2
of Van Helsing on the 5th, and Season 7 of
Once Upon a Time on the 6th.
Finally, grab your wire-wrapped baseball bat
replica, or whatever, and settle in for Season
8 of The Walking Dead on the 23rd.
"Ha ha ha, easy peasy lemon squeezy!"